if you're in a really competitive market
then you need to create a niche for
yourself and be the best at one certain
thing if you want to win customers hi
I'm Evan Carmichael and I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help so
today I mason a question from one of our
Facebook readers mercy who wrote in
saying I'm an author and would love some
tips on how it can work for myself as a
freelance writer so thanks for writing
in mercy you are in one of the most
competitive fields there is freelance
writing is really tough you're going up
against huge competition and it's a race
to the bottom you can go on text broker
and get someone to the right our
articles for you for a cent per word I
sent per word it's a race to the bottom
it's it's terrible and the quality often
sucks but it's hard for people to tell
the difference between somebody good
like yourself and somebody else who just
calls them a freelance writer so it's on
you to show how you're different than
everybody else and a really great way to
do it is to nice yourself out so think
of another strong passion of yours and
trying to combine it so there's be a
freelance writer because everybody is a
freelance writer try to find something
else that you're deeply passionate about
that you absolutely love doing
absolutely love writing about and be the
best at that as well if you can combine
those passions and promote it then you
want to be known as the guy to hire for
these kinds of writing projects not just
any kind of freelance writer a quick
example a friend of mine his name is
Anton he's a copywriter and already just
being a copywriting separated yourself
from all the other writers but still
there's a lot of copywriters so how do
you stand out in a really competitive
field what he does is he calls himself
the LinkedIn bio specialist and what
he'll do is he specializes specializes
in copywriting people's linkedin BIOS
helping them drive more business through
LinkedIn through there well written BIOS
and not gets him attention and he
rewrote my LinkedIn bio
and then I hired him to write a sales
letter for me and it can lead to more
and more business but you need your way
in you need something that helps you
stand out from everybody else that
drives attention drives awareness and
once they like you know you trust you
enjoy working with you they're going to
hire you for more projects so Anton is
out now promoting himself as the
LinkedIn specialist and he'll write the
guys like Jack Welch on Twitter and
offer to redo their LinkedIn BIOS and it
leads the business for him not just in
creating a linkedin bio because that's a
small job but when people are impressed
with what he does they say hey can you
also do this can you write our sales
letter for us can you write our
newsletter copy for us can you write our
landing page copy for us so it leads to
more business you have to find another
way another passion of yours to help you
stand out it's not just words it's not
just promotion it has to have some teeth
to it you have to feel it you have to
love this extra thing that you're doing
you love writing about XYZ and you are
the best in the world at doing it I hope
that helps for those of you who are like
mercy if you're in a competitive field
and we all are there's increased
competition you're up against the whole
world you have to find a way to stand
out you have to do it by combining your
interests because nobody can compete
with who you are so combine those
passions put yourself into the business
tell them your story why you started
this business let them see your passion
let they catch it like a fever and
they'll want to do business with you
you'll be known as the certain expert
for whatever topic you want to be known
as that will help drive your business
and will help you stand up your
competition those are you watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below always makes you want to
do more videos for you and I'd love to
hear what you have to say about this
video or if you have a question for your
own company always leave it in the
comments below I read those I checked
them in the morning when I'm eating my
breakfast I love seeing them come in so
thank you and I'll see you on
next episode
[Music]
you
you
[Applause]
[Music]